my uh
erstwhile mit colleague bob solo got the
nobel prize
not yesterday but about 30 years ago for
um describing that most improvements in
living standards from come from tech
progress
and paul romer later got a nobel prize
for noting that investments in r d
and human capital can speed the rate of
tech progress so if we do that then
we'll be healthier and wealthier
yeah from an economics perspective i
remember taking an undergrad
econ you mentioned econ 101. it seemed
from all the plots i saw that r d is an
obvious you could call it
as close to free launches right as we
have it seemed like obvious that we
should do more
research it is like what what like
you know there's no well we should do
basic research i mean so well let me
just be clear
it'd be great if everybody did more
research um and i'd make this thing
to apply development versus basic
research
so apply development like you know how
do we
get this this self-driving car you know
feature to work better in the tesla
that's great for private companies
because they can
capture the value from that if they make
a better self-driving car system
they can sell cars that are more
valuable and they make money so there's
an incentive
there's not a big problem there and
smart companies amazon
tesla and others are investing in it the
problem is with basic research
like coming up with core basic ideas
whether it's in nuclear fusion or
artificial intelligence or biotech there
if someone invents something it's very
hard for them to capture the benefits
from it's shared by everybody which is
great in a way but it means that they're
not going to have the incentives to
put as much effort into it there you
need it's a classic public good
there you need the government to be
involved in and the us government used
to be
investing much more in r d but
we have slashed that part of the
government really foolishly
and uh we're all poorer significantly
poorer as a result growth rates are down
we're not having the kind of scientific
progress we used to have um it's been
sort of a uh
a short term you know eating the seed
corn whatever
you know metaphor you want to use where
people grab some money put it in their
pockets today
but five ten twenty years
later they're a lot poorer than they
otherwise would have been
you